لقد كنا مستقلين في مجال الطاقة، وسرعان ما
أصبحنا مهيمنين على الطاقة ولم
يفعل أحد ما فعلته، لقد
انخفض سعر النفط إلى 87 دولارًا، وفي الواقع انخفض إلى أقل
من ذلك، وفي بعض الحالات كان علينا إنقاذ
شركات النفط من أن السعر كان
يصل إلى هذا الحد.  كنا نقوم بعمل لا يصدق،
كان لدينا أعظم اقتصاد في تاريخ
بلادنا، وربما أعظم
اقتصاد في تاريخ العالم،
ونحن مستقلون في مجال الطاقة، وسنصبح قريبًا مهيمنين على
الطاقة، وكنا سنكون
أكبر من روسيا والمملكة العربية السعودية
مجتمعتين مرتين  لدينا ذهب
سائل تحت أقدامنا أكثر من
أي دولة أخرى، وقد أنهى هؤلاء الحمقى الأغبياء الأمر
وانخفضت الطاقة من 1.87 وحتى
أقل بالنسبة للبنزين للسيارة، فقد
انتقلوا من سبعة وثمانين دولارًا إلى خمسة وستة وسبعة
وثمانية وحتى تسعة
دولارات و  تجاوزت فواتير الكهرباء
السقف وفواتير التدفئة الخاصة بك
تجاوزت السقف وهذا ما بدأ
التضخم ولم يتوقف لأن
الناس يدفعون الآن ثمن لحم الخنزير
المقدد والبيض وضعف
ما كان عليه قبل فترة قصيرة.  لقد
أنشأنا أعظم اقتصاد في التاريخ
أريد أن أصل إلى ناخب آخر كايتلين
بوسينو طالبة هنا في كلية سانت أنسيلم
وهي جمهورية وستكون هذه
أول انتخابات تصوت فيها
ما هو سؤالك للرئيس
كايتلين مرحباً بالرئيس تشونغ، شكراً لك
شكرًا جزيلاً على حضوركم، لقد
أوضحت الإدارة الحالية أننا
يجب أن نستمر في تقديم
المعدات العسكرية إلى أوكرانيا حتى يتمكنوا من
الدفاع عن أنفسهم. هل تؤيد هذا
القرار وكيف ستتعامل مع
التهديد المتزايد الذي يشكله فلاديمير
بوتين أولاً؟  شكرًا جزيلاً لك،
إنه لطيف حقًا وهو
سؤال مهم جدًا لأننا
نتخلى عن الكثير من المعدات، وليس
لدينا ذخيرة لأنفسنا الآن،
ليس لدينا ذخيرة لأنفسنا،
نحن نتخلى عن الكثير ولكن إليك
الشيء الذي يجب أن أقوله في البداية لم
يعد مهمًا لو كنت رئيسًا لما حدث هذا
أبدًا، وحتى
الديمقراطيون يعترفون بأن بوتين كان يعلم أن ذلك لم
يكن ليحدث أبدًا وأن خط أنابيبه لم
يكن ليحدث أبدًا، والكثير من
الأشياء لم تكن لتحدث أبدًا.  لكن
هذا لم يكن ليحدث أبدًا وكل
هؤلاء القتلى من الروس
والأوكرانيين ما كانوا ليموتوا
اليوم وكل تلك المدن التي تم
تفجيرها وتفككت على
الأرض والتي لم تكن لتحدث حسنًا
الآن، هذه هي المشكلة التي نواجهها  "لقد قدموا حتى
الآن 171 مليار دولار، لقد
قدموا ما يعني أنهم يقصدون
الاتحاد الأوروبي وهو تقريبًا
نفس حجم اقتصادنا تمامًا، لقد
قدموا حوالي 20. لذلك نحن في 170
لنفترض وهناك 20. اه، لا تفعل ذلك"  ليس من الضروري أن
نعرف الكثير عن التاريخ حتى
ندرك جغرافيتنا لندرك
أنهم أكثر فعالية قليلًا
منا، لذا عليهم أن يستثمروا
الكثير من المال لأنهم
يستغلوننا مثل أي شخص آخر.  لقد فعلت دولة أخرى
هذا هو السبب في أنني أنهيت اتفاقية التجارة
الحرة لأميركا الشمالية (NAFTA) واستبدلتها باتفاقية التجارة الحرة الأمريكية (USMCA) في المكسيك، لكنني
كنت أطرح سؤالاً سيدي الرئيس، يجب أن أعرف أنني
لا أعرف أي ديمقراطيين قالوا
إنهم لا يعتقدون أنه كان سيتم
غزو بوتين لو كنت رئيسًا ولكن
سؤالها هو هل ستستمر في منح
أوكرانيا المال والأسلحة إذا تم
انتخابك؟ ما هو الجواب؟ لدي
علاقة جيدة جدًا مع الرئيس
زيلينسكي لأنه كما تعلم فقد
دعمني في خدعة
الإقالة الزائفة رقم واحد
عندما  قال إن
الرئيس لم يرتكب أي خطأ،
لذلك
صادف أنني أحببت نعم، هذا صحيح، لقد
تمت تبرئتي تمامًا بالمناسبة، مجرد
مضيعة للوقت والمال، لقد تم
عزلك بسبب ذلك، نعم ولكن دعنا
نبقى في الموضوع هنا سيدي الرئيس لأن
السؤال هو هل ستعطي أوكرانيا
أسلحة من قبل امرأة مجنونة تدعى نانسي ولكن
السؤال هنا هو هل ستمنح
أوكرانيا الأسلحة والتمويل إذا كنت مكانها،
سأجلس واسمحوا لي أن أضع الأمر
جانبًا، إذا كنت رئيسًا فسوف أخوض
تلك الحرب  استقر في يوم واحد خلال 24 ساعة
[تصفيق]
سألتقي بزيلينسكي كلاهما لديه
نقاط ضعف ولديهما نقاط قوة وفي
غضون 24 ساعة ستتم تسوية تلك الحرب
وستنتهي،
بالتأكيد هل تريد أن تفوز أوكرانيا
بهذا  الحرب
اه، لا أفكر من حيث الفوز
والخسارة، أعتقد من حيث
تسوية الأمر حتى نتوقف عن قتل كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص وكسرهم، هل
يمكنني فقط متابعة ما قلته أنك
لا تعتقد أن عليك القيام به هو
تابع ذلك لأن هذا
عذر مهم حقًا، هل
يمكنك أن تقول إذا كنت تريد أن تفوز أوكرانيا أو
روسيا بهذه الحرب،
أريد أن يتوقف الجميع عن الموت، إنهم
يموتون روسًا وأوكرانيين، أردت
التوقف عن الموت
وسأفعل ذلك.  سأفعل ذلك
خلال 24 ساعة، سأفعل ذلك، أنت
بحاجة إلى سلطة الرئاسة للقيام
بذلك ولكنك لن تقول أنك تريد أن
تفوز بأوكرانيا، أنت تعرف ما سأقوله،
سأقول هذا أنا  نريد من أوروبا أن
تقدم المزيد من الأموال لأنهم يريدون 20
مليارًا ونحن لدينا 170 مليارًا
ولا ينبغي لهم الرد وعليهم
التعادل، فلديهم الكثير من الأموال التي يجب عليهم معادلتها لقد حصلت عليها مع الناتو عندما
جلست، حصلت عليهم  أن أدفع مئات
المليارات من الدولارات التي لم
يدفعوها في عهد أوباما وبوش وكل
هؤلاء الرؤساء الآخرين، ولهذا السبب فهم
قادرون على مساعدتهم في خوض الحرب
بسبب الأموال التي حصلت عليها ولكني أريد
الأوروبيين أريد أوروبا أن تفعل ذلك.  استثمروا المزيد من
الأموال لأنهم يسخرون منا، ويعتقدون أننا
مجموعة من الحمقى، فنحن
ننفق 170 مليار دولار على
أراضٍ بعيدة، وهم بجوار
تلك الأرض مباشرةً،
وسينتظرون 20 مليار دولار.  لا تظن ذلك
عندما يتعلق الأمر بما يحدث هناك
عندما كنت في منصبك قلت
إنك تحترم الرئيس بوتين هل
مازلت تحترمه اليوم أه لقد ارتكب
خطأً فادحًا ربما التقى وهو
رجل ذكي كما تعلم أتذكر قلت هو
كانت ذكية كانت ذكية قال
الرئيس الحادي عشر للصين صحيح ذكي
حسنًا 1.5 مليار شخص إنه حاكم
1.5 مليار شخص قلت نعم إنه
رجل ذكي كيف يجرؤ على القول إنه ذكي
بالطبع إنه ذكي يريدون منك أن تقول
إنه غبي  الشخص حسنًا، إنه ليس
شخصًا غبيًا، إنه ذكي جدًا، إنه
ماكر جدًا، وقد ارتكب بوتين خطأً فادحًا في
رأيي، ما هو اسمه، كان خطأه
يحدث، لم يكن ليذهب أبدًا
لو كنت رئيسًا، اعتدنا أن نتحدث عن
ذلك أولاً، أليس كذلك؟
أعتقد أنك تصدق
ماذا تعتقد أن
بوتين مجرم حرب
وهو مسؤول عن مقتل
الآلاف حسنًا، أعتقد أن هذا
شيء لا ينبغي مناقشته
الآن، بل يجب مناقشته لاحقًا لأنه
الآن يتعين علينا شن حرب إذا
لنفترض أنه مجرم حرب، سيكون من
الصعب جدًا عقد صفقة لإيقاف هذا
الشيء لأنه إذا كان سيصبح
مجرم حرب حيث سيذهب الناس
ويقبضون عليه ويعدموه،
فسوف يقاتل بقوة أكبر بكثير من ذلك.  إنه
يقاتل كما تعلم في ظل
الظروف الأخرى أه هذا شيء سيتم
مناقشته في وقت لاحق الآن
نريد أن ننهي تلك الحرب وأنا لا
أتحدث عن المال أيضًا أنا
أتحدث عن كل الأرواح التي
هي رقم  إن عدد الأشخاص الذين قُتلوا
في تلك الحرب أكبر بكثير مما تسمعه
عندما يفجرون مدينة
وتنهار تلك المباني ويقولون إن
شخصين أصيبا، لا، لا المئات
والآلاف من الأشخاص يُقتلون
وعلينا أن نحسم تلك الحرب